hey you might remember that last year we
had these David Pakman show 32 gigabyte
USB flash drives available with
memberships I have 12 more of these I
had 15 on Monday I offered a couple of
them up during a recent YouTube
livestream three of them are spoken for
I have available for you 12 32 gigabyte
David Pakman show flash drives they are
available to you with the purchase of
any yearly membership and you can this
is not like Toys R Us or whatever place
doesn't allow you to combine special
offers and discounts and coupons even if
you use a 40% discount code to get your
yearly membership you can still get one
of these twelve free flash drive so how
does this work very simple number one
you go to david pakman.com slash
membership you select a yearly
membership it can be level 1 2 3 or for
any yearly membership will qualify on
page 2 of the membership sign-up process
you'll see that there is a coupon code
field now you don't have to use that if
you want to pay full price and of course
I appreciate you doing so you can pay
full price if you want a discount you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 that will save you 40% and
after you purchase it email me david at
david pakman.com and say hey I just got
a yearly membership I would love one of
those 32 gigabyte flash drives here's my
address and if you want to confirm that
there's still some available because
they probably will go quickly email me
first before you sign up and you can say
hey David can you put me down for one of
those I'll say yes I can and then you
can go and sign up so free 32-gigabyte
david pakman show flash drive membership
is the number one funding source for the
program and you can take advantage of
that at david pakman.com slash
membership will take a break I'm in Las
Vegas Nevada today at the mass torts
made perfect conference you can follow
me on twitter at D Pakman and we'll be
back after this